it always gets crazier uh this is what
was going on yesterday here's a tweet
from
MSNBC the far right obsession with
Fitness is going digital opinion why the
far right is really into Home Fitness
white supremacists latest scheme to
valorize violence and Hyper masculinity
has gone digital now we've seen things
like this before that's not the first
time that we've shown you a headline
like that you know from Salon or Rolling
Stone or something like that and it sort
of related to what I mentioned yesterday
how you know UFC these Fighters boxers
kickboxers all of these people they seem
to be a bit outspoken right now and
they're usually anti-woke because they
care about meritocracy they care about
working hard that's connected to Fitness
it's like go get yours be in the best
body that you can be in right like
there's a there's a beauty of that
there's competition which is very
counter to equity Equity we will all end
up in the same place so you can see the
machine is very concerned that if you
care about Fitness if you watch that
scary Joe Rogan with his big muscles
you're going to become far right it
really means absolutely nothing Joe
Rogan wasn't really having it he tweeted
out this
he retweeted the article and he wrote
being healthy is far right holy so
that's Joe Rogan's feelings on it uh but
you can see this is what they do with
literally everything if a new trend
comes out and that new trend lends
itself like working out does to you
taking care of yourself and eating right
and not being reliant on the machine and
not just sitting there with something
strapped to your nuts eating bugs while
you're in Zuckerberg's metaverse that's
not really good for them and by the way
this has been going on for quite some
time a tweet by end wokeness who I
reference on the show quite often uh the
regime wants you fat docile weak and
compliant and of course what you can see
there is the cover of Cosmopolitan
magazine with an obese woman and they're
telling us that she's healthy uh you can
see the ad on the right and we've seen
this in uh what would that what ad is
that that's Calvin Klein right and we've
seen many other of these types of things
and you can see why is it just again you
just have to think about it at the base
level you don't have to think about it
too hard why are they pushing
boys or girls racism is good fat is good
and not only those things but if you are
fit you're also in essence racist it's
to just keep you dumb and dependent on
them that's really it
foreign
[Music]